hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to final nights for a game
that I played the demo of a long time
ago and now the full release was made
earlier this year it's a game that could
probably be equated to the joy of
creation in terms of pseudo free roam 3d
instead of 2d and just general some
pretty good scares so I'm gonna get into
an umma see what I'm getting into
hi bud no you look at me friend I
remember you so if you remember this
game I'm in miss max Donovan hi max and
I'm a paranormal investigator alright
I've been investigating Freddie's for
over five years now and I know I know
I'm close to finding out what happened
mysterious disappearances summer murders
no bodies no nothing
IIIi need to know what happened it could
be about right through it get solidified
me as the manager soft Freddy's okay
[Music]
all right the man is soft Freddie saw
attached to this notes is the keys of
fredbears
I cannot disclose my name my origins or
how I found you but I will meet you
there huh I'm thinking that this is the
beginning of a mistake you are making a
mistake this is a trap just judging from
what I remember before this is it it's
bad it all started Wow Oh what caused
these symptoms what symptoms are we
talking about here I have no idea - I
got an inventory system now this is cool
it's some kind of like point-and-click
adventure style five nights at Freddy's
game and it's been a while since I've
played like a five nights at Freddy's
fan game but what did I just grab I
don't know prolly important but with a
little bit of point-and-click Flair and
I love me a pointed click game I love me
a point and click game out won't go
together well I wasn't trying to make it
go together the public likes attention
but he doesn't like to be seen you can
see how I'm getting mixed signals here
just click OK my face a little toasty
but that's alright let's go in here
and interesting very interesting very
interesting very very interesting 1973
huh that's a good bit of ways ago will
cause these symptoms oh hi
why are the gas cans so glowy I don't
even know if I need the gas kids
oh yes what's that doing in a restaurant
of all places I don't know you're the
paranormal investigator man why don't
you tell would weird oh this is bizarre
I like I like I like it I like it I
think I like it I'm not a hundred
percent sure if I like it but I like it
let's see okay in here oh not a sixteen
fifty five divided by 30 is that
actually what it's supposed to be 1973
all these are pointing towards 1973
that's got to be it how about 1973 yeah
uh-huh
maybe they uh wait am i stupid 73 oh it
was from the top down why I was I was
going along the line there it doesn't
matter
hey why no go back
what are you doing you're just gonna
look at this and you're not gonna do
anything about it
hello okay so there's a pipe in there if
I can figure out how to get over there
that'd be nice I need some kind of a
crowbar
maybe I got one in the car
what's over here oh hi bathroom how you
doing oh good to see you yeah I love
bathrooms in horror games
oh yeah I'll put this here wait
hey on this there's no combination to be
found here yes so there's some on the
wall there do not breathe okay all right
easy all right why is that funny dead
body yeah it's nothing nothing ordinary
here I can't read alright nothing
nothing strange here just a big ol axe
in the back I'll take that thank you
looking for a crowbar got an axe you
know done mind if I'm handling a murder
weapon so good in this neighborhood all
good here alright let's move
it's mosey I feel good about this hey
excuse me
alright cool easy peasy lemon squeeze me
all done here I guess okay steam should
be done hi
oh oh hi hi hello how are you hey how
you do okay up licks in everybody
doesn't like to be seen oh this is that
thing that I'm not good at put down the
charger flashlight hi
oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap I don't
know what to do hello don't you see how
I don't know what I don't remember this
made no sense
yeah wait what wait wait you know oh
[Music]
okay I guess we're into the game now
good try and find guests or staff
members sighs the place is completely
empty you'll shut off the power not
something you want now is it now all you
have to go after any noise so whenever
he's taking a break to take in any
sounds or signals try maybe the alarms
in nearby rooms deleting them towards
you a couple of times once it's close
enough say party room one the ring the
alarm and near your office that's a
shift key remember Bonnie however is a
bit of a different beast you'll wander
around looking for intruders normally if
you wear your guard uniform
however didn't exactly fit the last
guards uniforms so until you can tailor
yourself a new one just try to avoid any
contact with him but if he does try okay
I got a problem right off the bat here I
can't get out of this menu how do why
are you glowing what is with your eye
what is over there okay I don't like any
of this also yeah I can't not be here
I don't know how uh-huh not be heater
guy my guy my main man
my big squeeze what are you doing what
are you doing you weirdo the puppet show
it's not starting you weirdo
alright so I'm probably gonna boys yes
just the long and the short of this and
the answer here is I'm going to die
because I can't get out Oh goodbye oh hi
what was that yeah I got I guess mom I
got her okay I got problems I got lots
of problems I got big bouncy problems
I got like it will not get me out of
this goddamn menu I what are they
pressed I see
for some reason W oh god that was not
explained at all oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god hi
hey how you doing hey um here we go
I was told that I was told to do this
this was an instruction that I was given
I was I was definitively instructed to
do this
Oh shooty shooty shooty hey but insky
don't kill me I thought you were just
gonna stand there okay so I was told
when one gets to party room one I got a
ring the bell I think I think I don't
know hey Fred bear you're real far so I
think I gotta lure Freddie over to me
right hey no Fred insky Freddie boy my
main squeeze
holy [ __ ]
no nothin my main moon you know I said
my main squeeze please don't squeeze me
I've got a lot of juice I want to keep
inside my body if you squeeze me all the
juice goes out of my body and then it's
still good to anybody especially not me
the guy who made the juice so please
don't no squeeze no squeeze a Niall
squeeze up saw oh [ __ ] I'm okay as it
turns out I was not a funny thing uh
apparently was not okay
apparently uh you know what I'm okay I I
was not okay in there okay great hey bud
can you get over here get over here ah
you pal
Fred man we have can you get your big
butt
get your big bare butt over here right
now so I can give it a big old slap on
the ass come on over here you silly
Billy cap your ass get your ass over
here you big bear but you big butt bared
you big bear about it
mayor you get that bare butt over I'm
gonna smack you right on the tuckus I'm
gonna give you a good old flap and
you're gonna be like no goodness
gracious that's probably what you're
gonna say all right whatever I guess
we're stuck here hey ding dong
Bing bong ding ding dong hey hey come on
you're being ridiculous what is that
oh why are these clawing hey you big
bear bungalow get no Bonnie Bonnie that
was not for you you big bunny I don't
want no bunny back you keep Fred hey
Freddie bear he's uh he's are coming hey
Fred boy I am here I exist just want you
to know I am here you cannot miss me
uh where are you what the hell how did
you get over there oh boy
hey how you doing hey bear but I'm gonna
get that tuchus wha I'm gonna get you
I'm gonna get that Dukas you go see you
go see but uh wait do I got to ring the
bell in the oh I thought it was like
more of an adjacent room type that Oh
goddamn no no no bear but bear but bear
but buddy bear but BA but bear come on
don't be like this but bear alright we
got issues
hey god I swear to god you suck but at
the same time go away go slap that ass
[Laughter]
I was gonna but you know you slap mine
first it's it's a slapper be slapped
world
get that bear but we'll get you all
right now I shut up I can figure this
out [ __ ] hi please beep yes hi hey bot
whoa what are you doing my dude my main
man
my main squeeze my squeezy be easy mine
easy squeezy by squeezing easy my
squeeze it easy please easy you suck
i you I hey you hold I take one of these
and take one deep I think I was supposed
to move and dance around and be an idiot
I got this oh my god there is what did I
just do to deserve this good fortune but
it what did i do did it what did I do to
deserve this
good fortune is he coming oh my god he's
coming
hey but I'm dancing I'm prancing Here I
am
hi what did I do enough did I do enough
what did I do enough oh [ __ ] did I do
enough tonight did I do enough I don't
know if I did enough could I have done
it could it be so hey listen
body I don't care how many times you
requesting I will not slap vine ass I am
only here for Freddy sorry I know it's a
shame hate you see leaves but I love to
watch you go if you know what I mean oh
crap I can't believe it I did it I did
this guy did it this guy you see this
guy this guy did it my [ __ ] Freddy's ass
I did it I'm a winner of a champion I'm
gonna call my mom mom I did it Freddy's
ours
maybe I shouldn't scream that from the
top man oh well good god finally that
took way longer than I'd be willing to
admit but I did it because I owe my god
where am I hiccups I got the fear
hiccups whose house is this yeah you
know good question
good cashton's all around I got nothing
in my inventory anymore
what the hell just happened Afton no
thought to be the Afton family house
wonder what's hiding in here probably
nothing good you know if I had to guess
I'd say there's a whole lot of nothing
good this is the creepiest part of the
game
just these adventure portions here where
you're just wandering through the house
trainer yeah laughs everybody ffff okay
[Applause]
ha hey is that you foxy all right I'll
just take these don't mind yeah I got
nothing to say about that you know I
actually I was thinking the same thing
there's actually absolutely nothing to
say about that perfectly normal thing to
have in your shed with a keep out sign
next to it perfectly normal anyway just
gonna take these shears hi holy [ __ ] hi
how are you doing good to see you you
know I got shears gonna go this way now
hi okay do I need to cut power or
something oh I do don't I oh I do yeah
this now it's a really high-tech wooden
fence the crank can set them free use it
but be wary the last person they saw
wielding it wasn't friendly what oh hi
big bowl Hey
oh my face why would you why would I
just stand there oh thanks what friendly
service thank you thank you so much oh
thank you that was great
really appreciate that laughing gasps oh
boy
it sure is gas nozzles in animatronic
mouth pieces sure okay cool yeah yeah
why not why not why not yeah sure whoa I
just see in there
nothing thought I saw something okay
moving on just moving on oh hi what is
do Oh all right whatever I just did I
sure did it well weird very weird can I
go upstairs oh I see over here oh good
gracious
that's a lovely bed anything need a
crank in here anyone in need of some
crank egde all right so where do I take
the crank to what needs a cranky yank oh
oh I did I did not add up
okay I didn't know that hello yes I'm
dad okay I guess I'm dead
okay guys I'm dead okay here we go let's
crank this bad boy I am really cranking
it oh I am just whoa Rick did I release
a ghost from that thing what the hell
happened what was that
what was that what was that anybody want
to run that by me again was that what
the hell are you okay so what I got to
do is somehow get out of here oh my god
no no no I'm sorry I'm frickin sorry
what just oh oh oh hi hey how you doing
hey what's going on
hey you look good how are you I'm fine
good to see you why did I go in here
there's nothing here for me I'm gonna
leave I guess
all right this great gonna go now gonna
leave oh I can go upstairs now oh okay
cool
good
oh well that was not oh hi hey how you
doin the light on chica for as long as
you can
I'm sorry what what what what what what
wait what what what what what am i doing
I have no idea what I'm - oh hi I'm
gonna do that yeah okay that makes sense
damn Nick not making sense game you know
making a lot of sense Gabe I think I
know what I need to do I think if she
could comes charging I need to run and
you need to go away right and then I'm
gonna turn around and run No
interesting I don't know how a man would
go into this house full of living
animatronics and be like I know I'll
just shine my flashlight on it I'll just
give it the old shine fixed right up
yeah ain't no proper boy is that not is
that is that fine is this fine is this
what someone would call fine doesn't
feel fine
doesn't feel fine at all it's the
opposite of fine that's not good
whatever is happening behind me not good
anyway
Jacob how is the good oh oh wait what is
that hot garbage where's this hot
garbage wait what is this hot garbage
was this hot garbage garbage is hot
garbage so hot oh hi you hot garbage you
garbage so hot what's wrong with you
you're hot garbage garbage is Stephen I
don't trust that good you keep faking me
out
you do the fakin bacon Oh God
his garbage is so hot I've never seen
garbage of this temperature before I've
never seen this this is the hottest
garbage I've ever heard or seen ever in
the history of forever what do I do
oh god I'm gonna die this is how people
die this is how people die this is how
people die I don't know what I'm doing
that why is that okay that's good hi
what did I win I'm doing with the game
told me to do I'm keeping my light on
chica for as long as I can that's what
the game told me to do this is what the
game said to do but it's following your
directions do I go here Oh God oh good
I'm gonna get you I gotcha
yeah I'm taking these with me oh hi hey
puppet how are you doing nice bow space
yeah
[Music]
see you're still sticking around I
presume nobody caused you trouble ask
them oh well uh I'll keep it brief
abstract for me of your important tasks
and actually on that note the puppet
master it seems there's a bug in his
programming right now where the p.m. and
AM if it shows time schedule for next so
he may or may not come out it's just to
eat them out you have to give him what
he wants attention looking at a buyer
the cameras should slow down his path so
I got a look at the puppet master is
that what you're saying I got a puppy a
puppy my see a messy puppy who's a puppy
wuppy who's our puppy puppy who's the
puppy wuppy your puppy wuppy whoa those
are pop a whopping it is me and it is
you who's the pop you up it's a puppy is
two pops Big O puppy up here up up here
Bebop okay I'm gonna say things it
actually what I'm doing now who's your
puppy wuppy and your puppy wuppy Bob
wait what hey wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait a minute wait hang
on a second hang on one hot one hot
second please one big ol hot second F
and you wouldn't mind I'm just thinking
that maybe just for a hot second you
can't do something like that to me cuz
you know that the hottest of seconds
that you're giving me not actually that
hot okay god I got a good focus today
how much longer do I need to look at you
okay got it wait there we go we okay so
working where did what ha wait why oh
hey bud can you please get over here
wait is he coming here or what's the
dealio who's that who is that the bunny
oh [ __ ] okay but a little that what the
Frick was that what oh [ __ ] I didn't
mean to do that
where did he go where's pop it oh hi
puppet hey bud how you doing what are
you doing exactly I'm not a hundred sure
what's happening here so if you could
not whatever it is you might be doing
don't just don't
simple as that oh yeah oh [ __ ]
okay I'm not moving I see why this is a
problem do I only need to not move what
he's looking at oh [ __ ] hey bud hey bud
who's a bod who is a bawd a bawd or D
hey bud you're a papi full of you hold
on what the Frick is that noise
what in the holy hell was that noise
what in the ever-loving holy hell is
that what does that mean
hi what in the undeniable where was that
who is that who was who okay Freddie's
going off again
Freddie's going off well I don't know
what that was about but that was weird
okay anyway Freddie's in here Ling Ling
Ling he's gonna blow in there you don't
need a lot of rings what I've discovered
you don't need a lot of rings he will
make his way downtown walking fast faces
pass setting so I'm about in his own
time it seems like if you ring him once
there he goes straight to the puppet
room and then you do party won't party
to pretty one BAM he comes it's pretty
predictable fairly predictable okay he's
there now so Ling a ding ding ding
bullying a ding ding dong there goes
it's pretty good that's pretty good okay
[ __ ] where'd you go oh God don't
whatever you're thinking of doing don't
oh god where's Freddie okay there is
right there
okay what's happening here what are you
doing exactly cuz I don't like it dick
dick where's he going
what's he doing what you do what are you
what are you doing what did you take
from them okay they're both in party one
see what happens I guess what did you do
to those animatronics what did you do
but I think I'm gonna run out of time
and I think it's gonna be okay come on
please time up now thought about now
please start now please yes time is high
do not come to me oh [ __ ] hey I'm the
greatest that ever existed in the
entirety of forever I'm beyond good in
every way shape and/or form all of my
shapes forms and or existences are the
best that ever existed and I am the
greatest okay great good good great
great good okay
good great um okay good great let's what
caused these symptoms okay so we're back
here then back in this keep on going
then let's just keep going
are you saying then you say to me had a
whole lot of nothing to me that's what
you're saying
oh uh okay
little little strange
oh yeah the sky you thinking you must
I've been kicked in the face with a door
piddly little kicks ain't gonna do
nothing to me play fair oh well
shockingly what no oh God
who are you I'm max Donovan paranormal
investigator I'm a paranoid are you
talking to me hello max those final
nights I saw things what did he do to me
he used gas to make you see those things
maybe I don't know he's a guest you see
those things maybe did that happen to
anyone else
it was everywhere even in the
animatronics themselves is that true I
don't know I'm just guessing here cuz
okay no how no man cuz I was just giving
it the old college guess what I was dude
just kind of like I guess anyway I know
lack of usage if he ever decides to
activate for one reason or another make
sure he doesn't stand still in any given
room for too long if that happens the
green three lights you might want to get
out of there a possibility it doesn't
make any sense at all
what is happening what's going on I
don't get it I'm exceptionally confused
what why are you over there now where
are you going how are you making it all
the way over there so quickly what are
you doing and where are you going - oh
hey bud how you doing okay I don't
understand anything that's happening
here you gotta move your tuchus there
you know [ __ ] Oh God
I've screwed it
I've screwed everything
oh god I've screwed everything up
oh where did it go oh god I've screwed
everything up I've screwed ever
absolutely everything is screwed oh god
what is that what is that I don't know
what I don't understand anything that's
happening hi buddy
listen buddy pal body but insky body boo
auntie buttinsky buddy boo oh [ __ ] okay
yeah go back go back
yeah you should go I don't know where
you're going I don't like this at all I
don't like anything that's happening
here
oh here comes her body you got a move Oh
God he moved okay he's kitchen this is
not good is he going you might be going
I don't know I'm running out of time
[ __ ] I don't know what I do with this
I'm not all represent sure what I need
to do about this this is a problem this
is a big problem this big big problem
the big problem is if there's a big
problem is Big Mac Bob a big bleep okay
did you just piss on my floor
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks um
all right so a bit of a problem a bit of
a problem and if a problem I have no
idea what just happened that's the bit
of problem that is the bit of a problem
I don't know what happened and I still
haven't gotten fredbear to cooperate
with me heeeeeyyyy
so there's a problem fredbear didn't
come somehow someway fredbear did not
come here oh look
something's happening over here that's
probably fredbear ripping out the power
that's great
oh you God did there's not enough time
is there it's gonna cut me off right at
the last second it is isn't it be the
longest goddamn song of your life please
please I call you so nicely to my room I
call you and you don't come by please
just a little longer little longer
little longer little keep God I could go
on oh but I promise you I'll give you a
good old flappy if you're just little
lumpy little oh please please oh my god
police a little please a little long
wait Wow
[Music]
okay they failed to do their task and
they're still trapped inside free them
by giving them another purpose okay can
do easy-peasy
easy-peasy ah hey the ones in there
failed their task okay she still haunts
but they've taken their tasks now free
and I'll show you more
oh oh I don't know if I want to see more
I'm okay actually I've seen enough maybe
not maybe what do we have here why was
this hospital abandoned I don't know ask
the city oh hello OS over here something
I need to know about probably haha
or is this just to the back entrance did
I not find anything actually special is
this just something that would have been
shown to me anyway I'm beginning to
think that yes maybe so damn okay
so there's really nothing here really
nothing really okay fine so I was dumb I
get it right
I needed the Kroeber to go to the back
to open the back door is what I needed
yep yep oh okay all right cool
interesting
FBI go any I go am I supposed to be
trying to reach a number here because I
don't know of any number that I'm
supposed to do I don't know what number
Oh 17 523
okay well that makes it easy 17 5 23 17
5 and then 23 well thank goodness some
graffiti artists downstairs decided to
give me the solution to this puzzle
awfully handy of them very nice actually
all right so I guess I'll just go back
down oh hi
Hey how you doing there bud yeah uh they
failed to do their tasks and their traps
inside you'll free them by giving them
another purpose I don't know what that
means
ooh I'm not doing a lot of paranormal
investigating just kind of wandering
anything no oh god I didn't know you
could interact with the environment like
this if I'd have known I would have been
interacting with the environment like
this huh weird
oh god what is that about what is that
about what is that what is that about
what what is that about what does that
mean I hate you I don't know what that
meant you see how you just throw things
at me then don't make sense and then I
die that's I don't know what you mean by
that
all right so that guy doesn't like me
being in that spot
I guess weird okay there's three locks
that I got on lock is that what I'm
understanding here oh [ __ ] not here not
here okay not here okay I get it
hello oh whoops
don't like to look at that let's go
towards it at first there were through
Oh
first there were five of us then we met
the two of them after those two there
were six of us five met two after those
two there were six of us right can I
write that down you might want to write
things down buddy you kind of
overlooking a lot of details you might
want to I want to keep track of things
oh really
five two two six easy peasy lemon
squeeze me whoo [ __ ] okay I'm out I'm
out I'm out I'm out I'm out what is that
all about really they're gonna be like
that it's an accumulative thing or
something what is this
oh [ __ ] what is that about
I don't know Japanese okay okay I did it
whatever I did I did it okay whatever
I'm doing I'm doing it I don't know what
it is but I'm nailing this I am
conquering all I am winning
I'm the best that there ever was
oh [ __ ] well I don't like that why did I
do that okay good great glad I did that
why did I do that
why was that a thing I needed to do [ __ ]
like that okay okay
Oh shine your light on the roof oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry
pie okay what that doesn't look like the
real chica whew I'm sorry I'm sorry
how would I how would I know
oh god why what are you talking about
whatever the real Jake God doesn't that
guy's dad's your guys okay so shine my
light on the real chica I'm assuming I
just gotta wait until it moves and then
click on it I guess
[Music]
yep that's all it is
I just gotta wait gotcha gotcha
what what happened because it's
hauntings brought in by a victim of
fredbear's oh I guess I'm done did you
save or am I going to die and then have
to go through all of that again
oh the next part might require some tips
oh you can click on various parts of the
room such as Beebe on the bed or the
hole in the wall that's W to look up at
mangle
use your flashlight to ward off the
animatronics turn off the lights with
the twits next to the door if the
creeper puppet notices you okay here I
go I guess here we go here I go here I
go here I go here I go oh this looks
familiar
wait yeah this looks a little familiar
okay
okay this doesn't seem so bad I see you
there oh [ __ ] that's not good that's a
bad thing I'm gonna turn that where's
the freaking what what's happening oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god that's
not good
what what what what happened
god damn you I swear to God
oh here what is here what is this what
oh yeah that's not good I don't know
what's going on oh hi that's problem
[Music]
okay so
I think I'm doing this right
Oh God
light there we go oh [ __ ] oh that's not
good what was this something by me I
don't know this is going to be asinine
oh okay it's fine not a problem what is
that that's not good what is that what
is that what is that what is it oh my
god oh god oh god oh god
Jesus Christmas jiminy Christmas stop
stop no you don't do that not to me how
is that a thing how fast do I got to be
on this okay so there's no preventative
there's definitely no preventative that
I can't I'm only reactionary this is
only reactionary I see I do any wasted
movement is death no no no no no no no
no oh no oh god oh god oh god I'm [ __ ]
I'm so [ __ ] now I'm so in every way
[ __ ] oh go go go go
what is that what what did I do what
happened did I win
oh yeah free her burn the plushie oh you
don't have to ask me twice
POW just tell me I'll give me a match
they'll do it burn it burn it up burning
it out of your baby I got no regrets
about that high
[Music]
what what oh okay okay
goodbye day whatever I do what oh [ __ ]
he gave me a poison I'm okay here he is
so all I gotta do is get him to come
over here you coming this way buddy you
better be you better be you Big Bear
bastard you big bear bastard I swear to
God if you're not coming down this
hallway right now I will be so mad at
you I will be so mad you bastard why I
am doing everything you want you bastard
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
will not go to my goddamn room what are
you doing there
oh [ __ ] whoa [ __ ] me
Shh
it's fine it's fine that bear bastard
I swear that bear I swear that bear I
swear that bear I am right here
ring-a-ling ding dong in and til the day
is long maybe it just needs one I think
that's it
I always do too cuz I get worried I just
need one that's all I need one sweet
delicious Bell one sweet savory Bell one
sweet sweet Pete Bell sweet EBD Bell
sweet EBT GT bill one sweet EBT bill and
that's it that's it all I need done and
done
hey bud you're fine Oh God you farting
bastard
you farty bastard you so much fart in
you stop farting on me okay just one
sweet delicious and he'll be here I know
this I believe this I know this to be
true where is the fart man there's the
fart man there is there he is
where's Freddie I swear to God Freddie
I've done everything you asked I've done
everything you asked Freddie
I swear to god Freddie Freddie you
son-of-a-bitch
Freddie use [ __ ]
Freddie Freddie Freddie Freddie Freddie
you you came you finally came [ __ ]
that's not good
wait oh God oh it's fine this is fine
Freddie Freddie I love you daddy I love
you here he comes he's a-comin which
means that I need to get that open
where's part man oh yeah he just left
hey bud hey nam i would never dream of
it man would never dream of using this
thing wouldn't dream of it didn't dream
of it i've never dreamed i don't have a
dream i don't ever dream I actually am
incapable I think even if powers cut I'm
still good I just can't be flesh that's
weird but I think I'm okay I really
didn't expect this power to be cut that
quickly
[Music]
what what happened
Oh God
oh god please oh [ __ ]
oh god oh god no no no not like this not
like this no no no no no come on I can
win it again yes a little victory twerk
hi bud hey hey dude the puppet master
here talks to me who wants me to ask you
if you know what happened in the
hospital these Burnham Freddie entities
that killed all patients a victim of
Williams terrorized the staff as we go
see on killing patients did William
really do all this he wanted this all
from the start
hold this he killed them now he's
missing nine five he what more can I do
what more could I possibly do Oh God
Oh God
okay you didn't show up this morning
I don't know whether that's or if you're
dead I can't see anything
I've gotta make sure it's that last one
there's no one here this is all going to
be over sue what you get it you can
survive the rest of the effects that
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] what was that stop it
Bobby you silly Billy what the Frick is
happening
what the Frick frack
not today oh my god
oh my god hmm
[Music]
not today I didn't even see you don't
exist to me if this son of a [ __ ]
doesn't be stupid he will not come near
me because he'll know what's good for
him Oh God
okay this is Wow brick Brack the next
stop is me right right oh [ __ ] know
you're down here Oh
Oh God okay okay okay I gotta hurry pay
attention this is go this is Excel cool
I don't need my god what is happening is
this all I got this all I gotta do is
ring wrong it's a lot of ring a lot of
wrong in Jesus Christmas I can do this
not sure how but I can do this if they
come at the same time it there's a clue
cool down on both of them easy not a
problem
easy peasy easy peasy
easy peasy I got this almost lost it
right at the end there
[Music]
almost got this I've been in utter
concentration for the past yes oh god I
don't think I blinked I don't think I
blocked escape shut your eyes to make
them disappear oh okay all right here I
go
goodbye see you around snooze you later
can I go please
snooze you all batteries oh yeah it's
nothing that's easy actually
let's see dog okay all right good great
good great let's whoops nap I'm good
thank you
I'm all set all set here Frisch though
big Brush big oh okay
I really blinked hard I blanked this oh
oh nah I'm okay okay all right then I
guess I don't have a choices but why
would you do this to me
what was that about the joy creation or
who you'll give me life oh hey hey how's
it going buddy well done you did as we
asked him even got the answers we needed
all right good
there's one less task for you to
complete then we will all be free great
good I love tasks tasks are the best oh
hey I get that that note from the
beginning was from p.m. as in the puppet
master I got your information second
table six wrongs that we're done don't
know about that thank you
oh okay well you're welcome glad I could
be of service
no I'm always here to help gonna help II
hope it kind of guy it helps all around
help E is practically my middle name
mark help e applier what they call me is
what I'm known as everybody knows this
everybody calls me this start a fire end
it all easy easy peasy can do you know I
know a thing or two about fires they're
hot that's one there usually some color
of orange that's two things I know two
things about fire you know very well I'm
mistakable really hey I'm gonna open
this now with my F it's a very tough
door purposely Duffey have a door but
nothing compared to me my man big strong
man alright now that I got the steam
going I'm just gonna go this way take a
gander from there I'm gonna go backwards
now what I need it all along hey are you
doing in here
well now that I got the steam going I'm
unstoppable
alright oh oh there we go
oh oh god I know my god
Oh am i alive somehow I survived the
explosion and unconscious in the flames
oh yeah this good Oh go now just gonna
skadoodle my little took us out this
door here
good thing I fell unconscious only minor
third-degree burns oh hey all right sure
hey spring-trap could it be - oh I'm
running now apparently I think I think
there's a general gist of what's
happening here I'm making a run for it
I'm gunning it my little legs pumping as
hard as I can fall oh hey bud
oh you're harmless ain't you what
happened oh that's the answer to this
puzzle I'm dead I'm dead oh [ __ ]
this is this credit sequence is lagging
my recording it's too intense the flames
too bad my processor can't possibly
render all these frames do many frames
my frames my frames that was good I like
that a lot
it is important to remember that I was
frustrated at times very rarely but also
it is a game made by just a few people
as a passion project this is a passion
project that's what most fan games are
they're a passion project they don't
have to be made they don't need to be
made but they're made because people
love the source material so much and
that's why I can always respect the
amount of work that's put into this
thing and I'm not even like oh it was
bad and I'm trying to compensate it was
good it was really good it got me a few
times it was interesting it was engaging
I loved the point-and-click adventure
mechanics of it it could have used a
little refinement on where the placement
of the back button was but besides that
it was very good a lot of work went into
this and I can always respect that
always I can always respect that that is
an amazing achievement they have done
great things here I'm really proud of
them for putting this into this and I'm
glad that I was able to play it all in
one go it was a lot of fun and I'm
confused I am very confused and here the
frames french-fried was still going down
all my fries they're just throwing out
the window frames go on forever no
frames still pretty good I liked it a
lot bye frames God my frames old my
friend widest same medium rendered in
144 P I don't know
oh no still frames frames prob
Oh a lot of ash particulates not not
optimized I'd say for playing and
recording alright and there you have it
oh god they even kept up oh no it's good
we're good now okay well good that was
great I had a great time
I love these fan games whether it's five
nights at freddy's or any other game if
someone makes a goose game fan game
that'll be awesome because the passion
that goes into these projects is amazing
and seeing the creativity that comes out
of the community is awesome
i love every minute of it and i'm so
glad that i was able to play it and i'm
so glad that you guys were able to join
me on this adventure so thank you thank
you so much and if you want to see more
five nights at freddy's fan games or
five nights at freddy's in general the
links for those playlists will be in the
description just click read more you'll
find them right down there below this
video right down there or there's
probably a ton of my videos in the
suggestion feed over there check them
out watch on thank you everybody so much
for watching and if you know any other
five nights at freddys fan games so you
want me to play let me know in the
comments if you got any more thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye